[Musique]
[Rires]
il y a très longtemps à l'époque des
romains vivait un roi barbare quand ce
roi eut un fils une bonne fée lui
apparut et lui dit tout fils est
immortel il ne mourra jamais il
deviendra un grand guerrier et il fera
de grandes choses mais tout cela à une
condition laquelle c'est que tu lui
donnes le nom de lustucru aux actes une
hésitation car même pour un barbare le
nom de tulle lustucru est ridicule
cependant il accepta le prince lustucru
grandi et le roi son père l'envoyaient à
rome parfaire son éducation
comme il était intelligent il était le
premier partout ou plutôt ils auraient
dû l'être
mais c'est m ne lui donnez jamais la
première place parce que pour rien au
monde il n'aurait voulu dire ou écrire
premier lustucru le pauvre lustucru fut
donc un éternel second
mais il se dit je suis pourtant meilleur
que tous les autres
mais cela ne suffit pas il me faut
accomplir quelque chose d'énorme voyons
je vais conquérir la kul seulement la
baule c'était un gros morceau et
illustre cru ne pouvait la conquérir
tout seul il lui fallait une armée or un
jour dans les rues de rome
un mendiant l'arrêta pitié monsieur
donnez moi quelque chose
voyons les aventures les voyages et les
batailles
ça ne te fait pas peur or non monsieur
en ce cas tu entres à mon service tu vas
me soulever une armée et nous allons
conquérir
comment t'appelles-tu juin eh bien je
suis moi c'est ainsi que jules césar
demain le lieutenant de lustucru et ke
de ils devaient armer et à l'air
combattre le roi de la gaule qui du
cateau de perçage et of this mais les
gaulois qui était courageux et actif
manquer terriblement de discipline et
finalement vercingétorix dû reconnaître
sa défaite et se rendit à lustucru
celui-ci écrivit toute l'histoire dans
un livre dont il confia le manuscrit à
jules césar en lui disant apporter ce
livre aux mains leur d'irak lustucru a
conquis la gaule arrivé à rome j'ai le
césar dit aux sénateurs romains mois
jules césar je viens de conquérir la
gaule
maintenant vous allez me nommé empereur
sinon je lance mon armée contre vous et
les romains le nommèrent empereur le
pauvre lustucru compris qu'une fois de
plus on lui avait volé la première place
le temps passa et lustucru chutent
encore de grandes choses
c'est lui qui devant clovis casas le
vase de soissons c'est lui qui sonna du
corps à roncevaux du guesclin c'était
lustucru jeanne d'arc c'était encore
lustucru et c'était pas napoléon qui
traversaient le pont d'arcole à pied non
c'était toujours lustucru et malgré
toutes ses actions d'éclat son nom
restaient inconnues dans l'histoire
complètement découragé il s'en alla
trouver la grande sorcière de la rue
mouffetard
bonjour madame la sorcière
voyez-vous jeu suivant braves est
immortel cependant personne ne sait que
six mois lustucru qui est fait de si
grandes choses à faire pour être prêt
dans une chanson
[Musique]
alors il s'installa dans un petit
village où il acheta une maison et toute
la journée
il regarda sa voisine d'en face une
certaine madame michel louis qui vivait
avec son chat à france 2 la regarder et
il en devint amoureux alors un jour il
acheta un bouquet et a lâché sa voisine
[Musique]
vous désirez et bien voilà je suis votre
voisin et je désire vous épousez
impossible mais je vous connais à peine
comment vous appelez-vous m'appelle
lustucru rires je n'ai pas envie
avec un nom pareil tâte ridicule aux
yeux toupie et une fois de plus le
pauvre lustucru été victime de son nom
mais cette fois il était amoureux et il
ne sera pas pour battu or un soir il a
perçu dans la rue le chat de sa voisine
miné et des mini mini mini il le saisit
l emporte un bain le lendemain la mère
michel à sa fenêtre se lamentait où
elles ont osé faire du monde imminente
mais non vous ne l'avez pas perdu il est
chez moi je viens chercher tout de suite
à je n'ai pas dit que je vous le rende
est et je ne peux pas vivre sans mon
chien et bien alors épouse et moi et je
vous le rendrai et si je refuse je le
mange c'est entendu je vous épouser
merci madame michèle au moment où les
nouveaux mariés sortaient de l'église
les enfants du pays se mirent à chanter
sacha guitry
c'est la paire de skis prix qui avait
bondi depuis ce temps le père lui s'est
cru vie parfaitement heureux dans son
petit village avec sa femme et le petit
chat